and I'll never forget walking into the
room it was a rainy day in New York with
downtown and I walked into a room and
absolutely sopping wet and there was
Julianne Moore and she said you even
look like my son I was like I've never
been so grateful for my freckles in my
life I was like thank you so let's get
right to the meat of it what's it like
being a heartbreaker oh god I don't know
that I'm suddenly not a heartbreaker
there's a serious side to that question
so you seem willing as we witnessed in
the clip reel there and anyone who's
been following your your work
you seem willing to really take on
characters that demand the audience
engage in a physical reaction themselves
whether it's emotional in that I guess
in a classic Hollywood way you'd say in
a tearjerker or in a horror scenario or
a kind of you know some sort of real
tragedy that's a risk as an actor to
take with an audience that you're asking
them actually to be with you rather than
to want to be you and I'm just wondering
if that's something that's conscious for
you as you're creating these characters
knowing that you you were actually in
you potentially are inciting a reaction
that might be very physical for your
audiences oh that's a great question is
the heartbreak know that the heartbreak
um there are various things I suppose
the first thing for me is the idea of
choice the idea that you have choice I
want to make it absolutely clear from
the get-go that I I get to do something
I'm absolutely passionate about
something I love since I was a kid um
but but there's no question that this
idea that one strategizes or makes
really specific career decisions I mean
they're one dreams of that but very few
people in this industry have that choice
and so whilst there have been moments
when I've been lucky to be able to say
yes or no to something there's also been
a lot of auditioning for things that
whatever it is try and try to retain
employment um but that being said I
think what you're referring to
is an emotional or a visceral reaction
to something and I am someone that I'm a
pretty indecisive person by nature and
I've learnt over the years to try and
train myself to to live by instincts and
and when I first read a script I'm a
really bad reader a very slow reader
takes me forever and I'll do anything to
distract myself but if I'm kept engaged
by something and if I feel an emotional
reaction like I did when when I read
Lemmy's and also I had seen the stage
show but but certainly with the theory
of everything and my week with marylin
there were absolutely visceral moments
or with savage grace one of the films
that you saw there which I'm not not a
huge amount of people have seen but it
was a film with Julianne Moore and that
wasn't that was again a very visceral
reaction I had to it so I try and trust
those interesting well we're very glad
you do because they they work you know
we we get engaged and certainly with a
theory of everything I mean I'm not
alone in having left the theater and
tears but also inspired in a way but I
think what made me really think about it
is folks of your generation and younger
and and even older at this point it
feels like there's this push to be the
kind of superhero movie star right so
that you're this character that's very
aspirational that audiences would go in
and I want to be that guy or that gal
and you seem determined to act and be a
movie star and to really again engage
with an audience that doesn't aspire to
necessarily be you but to actually be
with you or your character and that also
perhaps allows for vulnerability in you
that you know audiences think that maybe
you're more approachable or something
rather than being up here on this
pedestal and I know you said it's not
all about distinct choices that you're
able to make but it does seem that
you've able to navigate that say what I
also think is interesting is that the
term movie star is one that what you
know in Los Angeles people often go you
know they'll literally ask that question
do you want to be a movie star and I
always respond I don't know what that
means
you're already one I think I am by a
tool but I think there's something
don't get me wrong I also love those
films and I've been up for a fair share
of them and had really interesting
experiences I did a film it's not a
superhero movie but a big sci-fi sort of
space opera called Jupiter ascending
that comes out next year with a witch
house keys and and and every job has its
own own challenges and that I mean I
mean that was really an extrordinary
challenge in its own right because I
have a limited imagination and when you
work with witch house keys they have
such an extraordinary imagination that
when you go to work with them it's like
you're jumping into their world and you
have to trust them entirely and my fear
with that film a lot of which was shot
on green-screen was this idea that you
know what if you can't imagine it right
what if you can't you can't take
yourself there and I thought that might
be quite restricting but in the end it
ended up being one of the most
liberating things because actually you
give yourself over entirely to the
directors whereas on something like
Hawking the theory of everything you
know educating yourself about every
single detailed element around it is it
was such a different process but but one
of the things that I I keep filing with
with this life which is an odd nomadic1
is that there is great variety to be had
and you've got like sort of you've got
to love the variety which I do and keep
challenging yourself in different ways
so you've touched on a number of things
that I want to come back to through this
conversation and we're going to be
drinking our vodka flavored water
throughout the conversation so if we get
a loose at a certain point but let's go
back to to the beginning to the
background I had the privilege of at
least seeing your mother if not formally
meeting her earlier this week and I have
to say she's a stunning woman you were
the spitting image of your mother it's
really a shame you're not a girl because
you would have been a beautiful woman
but you know I guess we can't have
everything and you and I are both kind
of cursed with this Baby Face disease
but you've been working since you're 20
you're now 32 if Wikipedia can be
believed you've been at this for a while
let's talk about you know
when when you started out and that
initial inspiration to go into I suppose
theater at first and then film soon
thereafter well I I come from a family
who are not in this world at all and I
just had that probably slightly
irritating a cautious enjoyment of
theater when I was a kid and and they
would take me to you know two lemmas or
Rob and so the sort of big musicals that
took me and my brothers and and and
Wheatley that there was a sort of
symmetry to that in the sense that it
was going to seal a mood when I was
about seven or eight and seeing the
little kid playing Gavroche you know
clearly taking the day off school was
getting to like run around be an urchin
be a hero all right looks like he has a
good life I want where he's got um and
and and so so I started you know I did
stuff at school and and I had I then
when I was like 12 or 11 or 10 years old
11 years old I they did a production of
Oliver in London which Sam Mendes
directed it was before I think he had
got into film and I auditioned and I was
like as I urge in number 46 a forward
slash book boy I had a named part I had
a specific line that went books you
order from the bookseller sir and it was
I remember it still it's a goodie a very
important plotline I'll have you know
and it's and I again I got to leave
school during the day I got to go to the
London Palladium and I got to kind of
hang out in the you know and but I was
one of hundreds of kids the cast changed
weekly and but I got I got the
bargaining and and it was amazing
because it was um firstly Sam Mendes I
don't think I even met Sam and as whilst
doing it because I was several casts in
and and you know they're big machines
these but I remember it stayed on my CV
for a long time until actually had to go
and meet Sam Mendes for a job at which
point I was like I should probably take
his name off given he'll have no idea I
have
have you met him Dean I have yes and
acknowledge that he remembers you nice
but the other lovely symmetry was then
jonathan pryce who's a wonderful actor
and has always been a great mentor to me
um
played Fagin in that production and
years later my first play in London was
a play called the goat um an Edward
Albee play and I got cast in that and
Jonathan was playing my dad and I
arrived on day one a set I was like John
we've actually we've we've worked
together before
and he went really so yeah I was in
Oliver he was all really really what
were you Oliver Dodger cuz he had
hundreds of birds I was like how's that
your number forty-three /but boy cuz I
forgive me for not remembering you and
remind us what your capacity was amongst
other things in the goat with Jonathan
you you told a little anecdote up so
well I played um it's an amazing play
it's a play that's set in New York it's
about um this sort of couple very
successful couple they have a gay son
everything is going fantastically well
for them and it transpires that the
husband is beginning he's clearly having
an affair and and then the affair is
with some called Sylvia who it
transpires is a goat and and the play
it's extraordinary because it goes from
it was a new piece of writing so it's
the first new player done and and it
goes from this like utter comedy like
this extraordinary thing to a depth of
tragedy and and it literally has Greek
elements to it and and I remember this
extremely thing of being able to be up
be offstage every night and he hear an
audience roaring with laughter knowing
that with somehow through what Albie had
written and what you know Jonathan and
his partner Kate were doing you know I
knew that the audience had been tears by
the end and that was really the power of
that world that excited me but I also I
got one of it was my first time ever in
the West End and my opening line I
wasn't in the first act and my opening
line was I came on in the second act I
was playing their son and the lights
went off in my opening line was you're
doing what your [ __ ] a goat thanks
and it was and then Jonathan by my dad
was like um don't swear in front of your
mother or something I'm like what you're
[ __ ] a [ __ ] goat your time you're
not a swear I said this
and to get to say that on the West End
stage being offered was that was a great
great moment for me
less good was the Russell a night when I
there's good wasn't when I had to snog
my kiss my dad later in the play when
the guys there's all sorts of confusion
going on and my family would come and
watch it and my brothers would basically
come and watch to watch my dad sort of
squirming as I went through I bet
jonathan pryce remembers you now yeah
he's a good friend thank God it took
several shots for so sticking with
theatre and we here in New York of
course remember your great triumph in
red not so many years ago and what
struck me about that getting back to
this this idea of choosing to be an
actor or actually being an actor you
know that your character Ken is dealing
with somebody who's a star right he's
star artists Rothko but at the height of
his powers but he's also faced with this
choice between commercializing his
practice and perhaps remaining true to
something and you're this voice of
reason
and you know I we do this we you know I
read you know about you I put things
together and say oh yeah Eddie's the
voice of reason and consciousness and
art art you know was that something that
really for you has resonated beyond just
doing the play because it somehow feels
like maybe it has um
Cody's stroking having someone who's
seen lots of your things finding
patterns is amazing kind of like being
on a therapy chair these are these
people you guys are enjoying this
therapy session for me because know
that's a what anak amazing point I yeah
that that play was at a period where
I've done some theater in London I then
got into film people often say this idea
you know theater is real acting and film
is this somehow a sort of a lesser thing
as far as the craft is concerned and the
thing that I found was when I started
doing film it took me four years after
starting being an actor to get anywhere
close to getting a part in a film and
that first film that I did I went to
Australia and I was playing opposite
Toni Collette to wonderful actress and
after I'd only done theater and after
like an hour of our first my first time
in front of a camera
after an hour she's like ed you want to
go and watch the playback and I was like
no no no the director said I'm I'm not
allowed she's like come and watch the
playback I'm like no no I'm not allowed
she's like come watch the play
thank Christ because my eyebrows are
doing this I was sort of basically doing
performance like projecting to the back
of the stalls you know when actually the
camera was here and the amazing thing
that I learnt through that was this idea
of of really distilling everything to
something that was closer to a human
truth and that's what a camera sees and
what I've always loved is varying those
two things and coming back to theatre
and then going back to to film and maybe
similarly that kind of that confusion or
oscillation between like Commerce and
art you know that by the point that I
got offered read I had done you know
still trying to learn I didn't go to
drama school so I still trying to kind
of learn by osmosis from other actors
and I'd work with some amazing actors
but I've done some scripts that I
thought were going to be great with
great actors that really didn't work at
all and some that I thought were awful
scripts but I sort of needed to work
that ended up being kind of interesting
and I realized I had there was something
alchemic that happens in film that I had
no idea about but when that play came I
was a bit disillusioned and when I read
it I studied history of art at
university and it was one of those
amazing moments when everything you're
interested in the commerce art the idea
of being theatre it literally being
about an artist but also this idea that
Rothko would turn up to work every day
in a suit in the Bowery and he'd turn up
at 9:00 and he'd leave at 5:00 the idea
of like artists practical artists
everyone trying to find form in the
formless is really interesting to me and
I find this life of being an actor in
some ways is so wonderful that you get
to do live your dream but but it's so
unstructured you're so out of control
you haven't you really do have very
little control that always trying to
find some sort of order and that was
Rothko's way and and but that whole
experience started as a little play in
London working with Alfred Molina who is
just the dream like one of the great
human beings and great actors and and
and we went on a big journey with that
and with Michael Grandage who actually
Felicity Jones who's in the
theory of everything Michael was a great
supporter of mine and Felicity's very
early on and that sort of how we knew
each other so it was a very um it was
amazing
moment that come back to you know your
generations ability to kind of merge art
and commerce which i think is important
because that was also I think a bit with
with Ken representing the Warhol's and
Rauschenberg's and the pop artists who
kind of came after who really were able
to synthesize art and commerce
brilliantly but speaking of Felicity and
some of the amazing I mean just going
through your your filmography and and
the work you've done you've worked with
some amazing ensemble casts and some
brilliant directors but you actually
seem very gifted at two handers as well
or not as well but maybe you know kind
of rarely so that you know I'm thinking
theory of everything which folks will
see soon if they haven't already
My Week With Marilyn Savage grace and
and red and in theater this ability to
care a kind of carry up it either a
picture or a play on an intimate scale a
very intimate scale between two people I
don't talk a little bit about that if
you have a preference if you prefer the
the grand scale of lame is or you know
or if they both bring different things
to you and are fulfilling the only thing
that I've sort of realized having done
worked for a few years now is just what
what scenario makes you work best and
and for me it's being given the
environment to be brave enough to screw
up basically and because I think often
the most interesting work happens when
when someone okay I've got a third idea
it's probably absurd can I try it
and those directors that go for sure you
know do it and it normally fails and
then but those directors are going to
try again rather than going to get on
with it it's costing money all of this
other stuff is that that's when I tend
to do most interesting work now part of
that is trusting the people around you
and so maybe what you're referring to as
far as more intimate element of working
in two handers is that of course when
you're working with someone that
intensely you
you you develop that relationship and
you do trust each other and you have the
ability to to be braver and to and again
to sort of make mistakes but I am
forever and having started in theater
and really being really illiterate as
far as film is concerned when I when I
look at amazing screen performances and
think that that actor may have met the
person playing his mother 30 seconds
before the camera started rolling
everyone including myself I used to go
yeah but they haven't have as many takes
as they want they really can't like they
really really can't like whatever that
first instinct is is often the thing
that's caught and so I'm in great
admiration for people that can really
make you believe when there is no
generally in film now particularly there
is no rehearsal time but one of the
great gifts of the theory of everything
at the Hawking film is that is that
James gave his time he gave us like he
gave me four months to prepare well that
that would seem especially critical in
this sense because it was not only the
you know the verbal but also the
physical very much in that which maybe
the theatrical performance is lent to I
mean read was also in a way a very
physical performance as well so what
happens when it doesn't work you've been
in a few projects I know we're here to
talk about how great is don't worry
we're not gonna linger on this stuff but
uh you've been in a few that haven't
worked oh my god what happened hundreds
like so talk no not hundreds it's a few
coin I won't I won't name them because I
don't do that but can you can you tell
as it's happened like as you're making
it and if so do you panic like cut or is
it never the ear has it not been the
case so far that you can tell as it's
happening oh god this is a turd like got
a move on
that's a great question and it's one
that it's like a constant like that's
that's the unknown that's why people say
don't invest in the film industry though
there is no guarantee and I've done
films with literally extraordinary casts
and you know really formidable scripts
that I'm like are we safe here this is
going to be and I'll be a bit part but
like I know I'm going to be part of
something wonderful in it and it really
won't work and on the other hand I've
done the opposite I really it's very
easy for me to to choose theater and um
and it helps that I'm I suppose I've
been lucky with the theater so I have a
bit more choice there and there I just
go okay this is like a proper equation
right imagine that
rehearsals a nightmare yeah the the
other actors and we all get on horrific
Lee and then we open we get horrific Lee
reviewed no one comes and sees it is
there enough in in a text is there
enough in a character that three months
on when you're performing to you know
you know quarter of the house is there
enough there to keep you going and
that's that's literally the sort of the
rule book that I try and use with film
you can't do that I mean it's that there
is the I did I describe it as alchemy
there's something else that happens and
the sort of control freak part of you
can't can't um you can't control
everything's and and you've never been
discouraged obviously not to the point
where you stop working because you've
been thriving but I you know that's the
hardest part for me to imagine not being
artists myself for being a miserably
failed artist I can admit is worrying
that you put yourself out there and you
do have to trust your collaborators and
then when it doesn't work that that
somehow you're able to process that and
move on well the thing that I've learnt
I think subsequently is that
everything's there for a reason and for
example there's a film called the Yellow
Handkerchief which was with William Hurt
and Kristen Stewart was the scene in the
film there and I was playing an adopted
Native American from northern Oklahoma
and I I remember actually gene parsegian
my manager who's here
evening I member I was in town he's like
there's this it's a wonderful script I
read in ours like it is beautiful is
like you should go for an audition I was
like I'm never going to get cast as an
adopted Native American from Norman
Oklahoma and he went he went go to the
audition at Elie oh you know and I went
to the audition and because I was so
convinced I didn't have a hope I just
sort of threw I described it's like
throwing mud at a wall I was like there
you go you know and walked out and then
and then I got offered the part and I
think I just had to go and speak to the
director to sort of tell him that that
what I've done in that audition was
complete like you know how was that I
couldn't do an actual part from that
that was just like I said oh is this
like a sort of moment of absurdity
anyway we went through the making of
that film it's a little film it didn't
have a huge audience when I was speaking
to James Marsh again um for the theory
of everything the director the theory of
everything he had only seen English
period dramas and those were ones that
I'd done and and he asked me on the
phone he said have you done anything
that's physically sort of outside of you
and I said I did this little film called
Yellow Handkerchief and and that film
which really didn't make much money
didn't have a sort of broad um I don't
know wasn't broadly released ended up
being the reason that I got cast in in
the theory of everything because he saw
that the the mud on the wall element or
like the jumping off a cliff element he
was like oh this guy can he's having a
jump of a cliff anyway he died and and
so that you know there was a sense that
in some ways these things are maybe I'm
not a tickly fatalistic person with a
dude that was there for a reason
ya know that actually is brilliantly
logical and I what I was looking to hear
and I should really say I don't at all
mean something doesn't work because it
doesn't find an audience sometimes the
greatest work doesn't find an audience
that doesn't mean it's a failure it just
means that it was out of its time or
whatever
savage grace which I for me is my
favorite film that you've done so far I
just think a brilliant piece by Tom
Kalin
you know I guess from the outside it was
probably a stretch that anybody would go
and see it a lot of people did not as
many as people will see
you hear of everything or certainly
Salamis but I'm just wondering any
takeaways I know that that's also a
project that's close to your heart now
that was a that was a project early this
is a true story about um the the family
that inherited inherited the bakelite
fortune and they lived in New York and
he married this woman from the wrong
side of the tracks and she was a huge
sort of extraordinary baekeland which
Julianne more players in the film huge
social climber and they had a gay son
who she ended up sleeping with and he
ended up killing her and it's an
extraordinary kind of Greek story and
it's pretty intense but that going back
to the visceral thing anything in it but
but it was a film that that when I read
the script it just had such vision it
was its own thing and and that was a
film when I was working in London
working in a pub in London and I
remember I've again gene who was here we
fought pretty hard to get in the room
because again you have no financial
currency no one knows who you are and I
got the part
and then the film the financing
collapsed because as you can imagine
it's not a massively commercial sell and
and then a year later I'll never forget
it I was I was working in the same pub
in London and the guy who was my manager
was about to go to lambda so about to
train to be an actor and he was kept
talking to me telling me um sort of
stuff about about his you know he was
with an agent what was he doing he said
oh I've got an audition tomorrow for a
film with Julianne Moore it's called
savage grace I said oh well it had to
stop my cells like me really oh that's
interesting
thank God well I was cast in that know
in my mind's eye that's gone and I
member calling cheating going there
making it and and and and he's like I
know but I think then maybe looking in a
different direction and and that was an
amazing moment in which Jean and my
agent in Los Angeles Josh I remember
they were going to heartbroken because
these people invest in you and and and
we fought our way back into a room and
I'll never forget walking into the room
it was a rainy day in New York with
downtown and I walked into a room and
absolutely sopping wet and there was
Julianne Moore and she said you even
look like my
I was like I've never been so grateful
for my freckles in my life I was like
thank you but but again on that film I
was then cast again and then the
financing fell through and it was like
you're you're you always try try not to
invest to you emotionally in these films
but but Tom Kalin who made that film
who's a mutual friend of ours is one of
these what I'm realizing now rare
filmmakers and it was made by killer
films who are in New York wonderful
producing house who really give their
directors authority and allow them to go
and make the film they want to make and
now one of the difficult things with
film is that everyone there are so many
people with opinions and what's
difficult as an actor is you just you
feel kind of fragile when you're working
and you want to trust one person's voice
you don't want to feel there's a stream
of people behind the committee exactly
yeah
so I'm glad you mentioned your freckles
and brings me to my next topic which is
look it's difficult then it's personal
and you can tell me to move on but you
know I I am always concerned with the
artists that that I value admire follow
their ability to to keep on and part of
that involves being on all the time
you're at you know an established point
in your career but you're you're still
you know early in years I hope you have
a very long career but did anybody tell
you'd be acting all the time
like the after the theater curtain comes
down after the lights on the cameras are
off you'd be doing things like this
you'd be you know on on the circuit
endlessly and also you know kind of
submitting yourself to what now has
become I find kind of abominable
behavior by certain elements of the
industry the publicity side of the
industry that you know I in researching
this came across a clip some British I
guess it was a night a late night show
or something where he had all of these
famous important people in a pen and
then he called you out and he was
telling jokes and then
to the point where he asked you how far
your freckles extended and I was like my
god
you know that's the point I would have
just walked out like nope you guys can
have all this I don't want to talk to
you anymore this is horrible leave me
alone but you were very dignified and
you made it through somehow and I have
to believe somehow that was continuation
of your ability to act through
situations Rogers referring to I cannot
say it was so hard for the Brits in here
as I did the Jonathan Ross show and I
just I I it was my first time doing a
British television show and I just got
off an airplane from Los Angeles and
went straight to the studio and I was a
mixture of jet-lagged but I had had
three espressos have half knackered half
wired and I walked on and he basically
asked me if I had freckles and and he
did and and it was I was a bit like well
what planning my own like well um but to
the Coryell question back I think it
take why are you here why are you doing
it but the core the core your question
it goes back to what you were saying
about the Rothko play which is Commerce
and art now I think and I don't mean to
be really pretentious about it but it's
the same in the Hawking film of science
and art Jane is it not studied English
um Stephen was a scientist these ideas
of opposites meeting one of the the
alchemy that happens in film is through
the fact that you have cameramen you
have people who are in charge of
lighting gaffers you know the
specialists I mean even with even with
the really the I've witnessed promoting
the theory of everything you know the
people from the from the studios who do
specific marketing for specific regions
there it's such a big team of people
with completely different skills and the
reason there isn't a financial model or
a model an equation for anything is
because there will always be that
collide now I part of the answer to that
question is I did films like savage
grace and um the Yellow Handkerchief and
I really try and pour everything into
whatever part it is and so I do feel
like when there's an audience you know
you don't that's a good thing
you
you're doing this to be a storyteller
and you kind of want to Pete want the
people to see the stories and so I think
this part of it promoting films I do
understand that it is of business and I
but beyond that not the business the
idea of people actually going and seeing
it and it's easy when it's something you
care about
and I think if you if you really look
closely at this there's a sort of there
is you can always see when those people
are talking about their films or really
it's because they're trying to encourage
people to see stories they care about or
Bravo to you and I really hats off
because I certainly couldn't deal in the
same way so now we're just a couple of
bullet questions and then we'll see
where that takes us is there anything
you've decided you won't do no what are
the best pieces of advice you've gotten
and if you care to mention
from whom feel free but what one that
one of them was from a theatre director
who directed the goat Anthony Page who
said trust your instincts but it's taken
me another ten years to work out how is
the second you haven't in everyone says
that like trust your instinct you know
but how I don't know my instinct is
thank you because the second you have an
instinct you then you then start
questioning it immediately and
interesting I heard a radio show with
Tom Hooper who directed Lamy and is a
friend and it was interesting when
someone you know really well but you
don't hear them talk about their sort of
look on the life and he said that that
for him he likes to make film sets
chaotic places because you're being
asked 400 and 500 questions a day he's
learnt to embrace that because what it
does is it makes you just like dad I
know what ours makes you do some weird
Thai trick no no but it makes you sort
of like give your instinct with it
before you've got time to question it
and and so that's one thing and the
other was I once read a it was
interesting time when I was starting out
with and like a lot of my best pals are
actors and I love actors
and and we would all go to start out in
London you know but what auditioning for
the same parts then in Los Angeles then
in New York you know always sort of
there's a sense of competition and and
it's by the fact that you're all going
for the same thing and yet learning that
these people become really really close
friends some of them - and how to deal
with that notion though there was a
quote by this sounds again quite
pretentious by um Chekhov - his wife
Olga Knipper which was take life step by
step pace by pace slowly slowly and
leave the competition to others and
that's something that I for one's own
sanity in this industry which is
fiercely competitive I try and do Wow
that's yeah that's brilliant
so keeping one sanity how do you keep
British traveling the world how do I
mean so I'm wondering you you've worked
at home you've worked abroad the
incentive I'm sure at this point will be
for you to be away from home more often
but I'm just wondering do you feel it
keeps you grounded to be able to work at
home or near home fussy how does one
keep British um you wear you wear suits
from Savile Row uh you um you fly
British Airways no you I suppose what
happens is that for me that's home and
everything I sing about like the the
nomadic nature of it I've loved living
in North Carolina living in Louisiana in
New Orleans New York I've lived here
while I was doing the play but but the
thing that I've realized with that
circus like existent and there was a
beautiful line in my week with Maryland
where Kenneth Branagh playing Olivier
turns to me and my character and goes
you you happy you joined the circus and
it is there is that element to it so but
I've kind of realized that that my roots
are home and that's somewhere where you
can come home and you'll just let
everything's unpacked and even if you
lock it up and go and live somewhere
else for you you know having that is
very important
helps that you know a lot of those great
theater directors I've worked with have
been British and those are places that I
instinctively kind of keep wanting to go
back to well we're incredibly glad you
joined the circus I think maybe Luke we
have time for a few questions three
questions three questions for mr.
Redmayne yes miss in the corner what did
he think of Emma Watson's UN speech I
was lucky enough to work with Emma on my
with Marilyn it was one of the first
things if not the first thing she'd done
after the Harry Potter films and I just
have extraordinary admiration for her um
I think putting your head above the
parapet to really talk about things you
care passionately about is is very
important and hence I did I'm not on
Twitter but the he fishy campaign I'm
fully behind I think she's an
extraordinary woman and a great actress
I think I saw one on this side
or was it about Emma as well yes
so the question is about savage grace
and how his relationship with Julianne
Moore kind of flourished and blossomed
through through that production with the
amazing thing about savage grace was it
was that again it was really early for
me so I was still trying to just to
sponge up any it's technique I could and
what I loved was the way that Julie
worked versus the way that Steve and
Elaine worked he played her husband was
completely the opposite
I mean Steven is a brilliant and quite
sort of cerebral actor wants to rehearse
once it took Julie as someone that just
like you know she's entirely spontaneous
and it was kind of wonderful for me
because I had these two very different
ways of working and and the son is kind
of caught in between and I in some ways
found that in a sort of stylistic way
that I was sort of caught between these
two different methods um I I mean what I
also learnt from Julie was was that the
craft side of the science as it were
that how cameras work seeing she knows
absolutely where everything is and and
she's very strong like that um but but
for both of us it was also it was of
quite a dream time we shot the whole
thing in Barcelona it was a beautiful
summer and and lost brilliant Spanish
actors I can harken about it but I loved
savage grace even though the subject
matter was pretty intense so I'll
reserve the last question for myself
then eh
will you promise to come back and visit
us on brought on Broadway stages again
and B will you take care of yourself
please for sure and for sure thank you
I'm convinced this a post at one point
that said the greatest actresses of our
generation listed all those names you
said and then in there was Hugh Dancy
Patrick Wilson so they're just like yeah
there's not enough to warrant actor you
know it's and if anybody ever sees that
poster and wants to get me the greatest
gift of my life please just just pick it
up and